data mining
and knowledge discovery have
revolutionized the way
that people interact with information on
the web
if i want to find pages related to a
particular topic
i can use a search engine like google
that
minds the textual content of web pages
if i want to find new movies that i'm
likely to enjoy
i can use the netflix recommender system
which
mines the ratings people give to films
and tv shows that they watch
but there are some questions that
traditional content-based data mining
and knowledge discovery
can't answer in particular
understanding information and
understanding how that information is
presented are two fundamentally
different tasks
so if i want to find inspiration when
i'm building a web page
or understand if a particular page is
designed well
or get suggestions for how to make my
page look better
google isn't going to be much help
these problems have all been studied in
the literature and
different authors have approached them
in different ways
but there's a single underlying question
here
if data mining and knowledge discovery
have proven
so useful in understanding information
content
on the web why can't we use the same
tools and techniques
to study design answering this question
is precisely the subject of my thesis
in particular i want to i introduce
website geist a scalable software
platform
for design mining the web bringing data
mining and knowledge discovery
techniques to
web design for the very first time when
you
think about it the web is the largest
repository of design knowledge in human
history
and it presents an opportunity to learn
about design
practice on a truly massive scale every
single page provides a concrete example
of
visual problem solving and human
creativity
and aesthetics and there are billions of
pages to draw from
the goal of website geist is to give us
a way to make sense of
all of this design data
the premise of design mining is to make
it easy for users to
quickly and easily find relevant design
information
understand that information by
distilling general principles and
recognizing design patterns
and then leverage that understanding to
power design-driven web applications
for instance by automatically
retargeting content
between different layouts and styles or
making a static
page responsive for mobile and tablet
display
in this talk we'll explore how design
mining can be used to solve
all of these problems but first i'll
describe the development of the website
geist architecture
and the principles motivating its
construction
website guys is fundamentally different
than content-based web crawlers that
statically analyze
a page's source to mine web design
website guys renders each page in the
canonical view
and then stores all of the resources and
properties that contribute to
the page's visual appearance to give
users a way to interact with page
designs
the platform computes a visual
segmentation of each page
along with a set of descriptive features
for every element in those segmentations
in most previous work studying the
visual composition of the web
a page is the fundamental unit of design
website geist and contrast operates on
individual page elements
allowing users and applications to
interact with data the design data at
multiple scales
and we'll see how important this
property is
later on in the talk
to segment pages into design elements
website guys leverages the document
object model tree
for many pages the dom provides a close
approximation
to the page's visual hierarchy but it's
not a perfect representation
many notes in the dom don't contribute
to the rendered appearance of a page
and there can be many different ways to
use the dom to implement any particular
visual design website guys canonicalizes
the dom by
identifying the elements that contribute
to a page's visual appearance
and then reshuffling the hierarchy so
that parent-child relationships
in the dom match visual containment on
the page
this generates a structured visual
representation
of designs that are directly comparable
between pages
on top of this segmentation website guys
computes a set of
descriptive features for every page
element which
users and application developers can
leverage
these features comprise all the design
properties we can think of to measure
including the render time html and css
properties computed by the layout engine
a collection of computer vision features
such as just scene descriptors
and a set of high level structural
properties relating to the page
segmentation itself
the website guys architecture is based
on four design principles
the first is consistency
the web is dynamic but machine learning
applications expect data to remain
unchanged between accesses website guys
therefore store static snapshots
of page designs the second is
completeness
websites is intended to be a general
design mining platform
if an application needs a particular
piece of data
website guys should provide it thus
website
saves all the resources and properties
that contribute to a page's visual
design the third is scalability
design mining applications need to be
performant with millions
or even billions of of page elements
websites replicates data in multiple
formats for efficient retrieval
in a wide variety of use cases
and the last is extensibility to
make it easy to build design mining
applications on top of website geist
in any programming language or
development environment
users interact with the platform through
a restful api
that delivers data using json
the website guys api is optimized for
three common use cases
direct or random access to specific
design properties
streaming access to retrieve large
swaths of the repository
for instance for machine learning
applications and
query-based access to allow for
filtering based on
design properties this
querying language the squaring interface
is exposed via
a custom query language called dql
or for design query language which
transparently converts user requests
into
sql or query language to abstract
away
the underlying data store so that
developers can access design data
without worrying about how or where
that data is stored in the repository
the website guys data set is an ongoing
project
but we see that the initial crawl with
pages from the
alexa top 500 the webby awards gallery
and popular design blogs we crawl pages
in a
breath first order and limit downloads
to 10 pages per domain
to ensure a diverse diverse repository
we also spoof http headers and request
both mobile and tablet versions of pages
so that we can understand how design
chain
designs change across form factors
currently the website guys data set
consists of around
100 000 web pages which corresponds to
about 150 million
individual dom nodes or about 15 million
visual design elements
now let's turn our attention to the
problems that
design mining can help us solve
one of the most universal problems faced
by designers
is finding inspiration examples
help developers by illustrating the
space of possible design solutions
and how to implement those possibilities
but where are designers supposed to turn
when they need to find
material frequently
they rely on hand curated galleries of
pages
that have been painstakingly collected
over time
for for instance here's an article on
a popular design blog showing a
collection of 40
horizontal web pages pages
that scroll left to right instead of up
and down
just just out of curiosity how many
people in this room
have actually seen horizontal scrolling
web pages
okay so a few um
but you can see now why this sort of
curation
uh can be invaluable to designers even
though you know building these galleries
is a manual time
consuming process with website guys
designers can dynamically curate design
galleries in a matter of seconds
here's a simple query written in dql
which searches the repository for pages
with screenshots
that have an aspect ratio greater than
10 that is
pages that are 10 times wider than they
are tall
and here's what we get when we execute
the query
now there's two important takeaways from
this example
the first is the ease with which design
mining can automate
tasks that are difficult or laborious
for people
and the second is the importance of
working with design data
at scale out of the hundred thousand
pages
only 68 or a little less than
.07 percent of the archive
match the query so to find even a single
example of horizontal scrolling
page to find a single example of a
horizontal scrolling page
we need at least 1500 pages in the in
the repository
and the point here is that you really
need scale to get at the long tail of
design
where a lot of this creativity is
clustered
another example of how this kind of
curation can be useful
is the is the canvas tag the w3c
introduced the canvas tag
in html5 and the spec described it as a
general purpose scriptable graphics
container
and when it was first proposed there was
a lot of confusion over what this really
meant
if you you know search google to find
more information
what you end up with are a lot of
tutorials like this one
which give you useful information but
provide little insight into how the tag
is actually
used in design
with website guys we can find thousands
of examples of canvas elements
deployed in real pages and start and
start to develop
insight about how the tag is actually
used you know animations
graphs rounded corners and interestingly
enough
custom fonts in fact the overwhelming
majority of canvas tags returned by
website guys are used to render custom
fonts which is in direct contravention
of w3c guidelines
so here design mining has helped us find
an instance where
prescribed usage differs drastically
from practice
the web font standard is so broken and
crippled that
designers have found creative
workarounds to guarantee that
they can control the way their content
is displayed
and another common problem for designers
is to be faced with an existing design
and want to find similar alternatives
suppose you're about to kick off your
new marketing startup
and you want to scout out the
competition
the french company milky has a nice
website
and finding examples of other pages with
similar designs could inform the way you
build your brand
this is a task that would be difficult
if not impossible
to perform using google
but with website guys we can translate
some of the high
level design properties of the milky
home page
into a dql query and search for matching
pages in the repository
these results illustrate how similar
layouts can be used to express
different visual themes and they might
be useful to help guide
the design of your startup's web page
now some designers don't want to
interact with website guys at the level
of code
and people aren't always able to
articulate what it is that they like
about a design
or what makes a design distinctive
but with design mining we can build
applications that
allow users to search for inspiration
in different ways and if you can switch
to the demo
um this demo that i'm going to show you
which is available on our website uh
provides the ability
to do query by example searches over
pages in the website guys repository
so here's the milky website again
but instead of writing a dql query where
we can simply so
we can just simply select the page
and then search for similar design
elements in the database
this search is powered by a distance
metric trained over the feature
descriptors that i described earlier
and uses locality sensitive hashing to
make nearest neighbor queries in the
feature space
run in real time and what's really cool
about this interaction is that there are
some pages here
um like the dql query we saw before that
have large headers
and top navbars but you'll also notice
other results
that are similar to the query in
different ways
so these such as pages with this you
know dark light dark striping
that you'll see so you know once a
designer has found a page she likes
she can click on it and
website guys allows her to close the
loop and
inspect the way that the page was
implemented
to inform the development of new sites
so you can see the html all of the
render time css properties
and this is just one example of the
kinds of new interactions
that design mining can enable can i
switch back
thanks
so design mining can also help us
understand the relationship
between the way a particular page
element is designed
and the semantic role of that element in
the page's information architecture
html5 was published as a working draft
by the w3c
in 2008 more than 10 years after the
introduction of
ht the html4 standard and
one of the most contentious features of
the spec was the inclusion
for the for the first time of a set of
purely semantic tags
a few of which i've shown here
highlighted in green
these tags describe the structural role
of the page content
but have no effect whatsoever on
how that content is presented or
displayed
and the contention about whether or not
these elements should be
included in the html spec was reflective
of the long-standing tension between
application developers who want rich
structure and explicit markup in web
design
and designers you know who just want
their web page to look good
in in particular there's a chicken and
egg problem here
these kinds of semactics can enable a
whole
host of new web applications you know
making pages more accessible
facilitating retargeting and improving
the performance of machine learning
applications
but web designers have little direct
incentive
to semantify their pages before these
applications
actually exist so another thing that
design mining can do is help us find
a way out of this problem by
bootstrapping structural semantic tags
on pages from design data
so we built a crowdsourcing application
on top of website geist
and used it to collect structural
semantic labels for page elements
we asked participants to select the most
important elements
on a set of web pages and then to
provide descriptors
that explain their role in the page's
information architecture
through the study we collected 20 000
structural semantic labels
for more than a thousand pages
now here are a set of spatial
probability distributions
from the data we collected each
distribution
shows where a particular semantic
concept
is most likely to appear on a web page
and from these distributions we can see
that the
visual presentation of page elements
and the structural semantics of those
elements are sometimes highly correlated
following this observation we trained a
set of
off-the-shelf binary svm classifiers on
the full
1700 dimensional website guys feature
space
from just the design information without
any content analysis at all
we can classify page elements like nav
bars and logos with around 90 percent
accuracy
some concepts like comments are harder
to reliably identify
but it seems likely that we can improve
these results in the futures by using
more sophisticated
machine learning techniques
the larger point however is that we can
take these classifiers
and run them over new pages predicting
structural semantic tags for pages that
don't already have them and once we've
predicted this data
we can make it available to developers
to drive
new applications for instance making it
possible
for designers to search for page
elements using semantic keywords
one final scenario in which we can
leverage design understanding
to enable new interactions is automatic
retargeting
a common practice on the web is to adapt
the designs of other pages
for new content so here we have an
example of a phd student
who built himself a nice website
and then two professors who stole it
usually the way that one goes about this
is by copying bits of content
and html between pages this can be an
effective way to explore new designs
but as we show here it's also a manual
time consuming process
that operates at the level of source
code and requires significant technical
sophistication
and when people transfer content in this
way
they are implicitly establishing
correspondences
between page elements in effect inducing
a mapping between pages
so if we could algorithmically reproduce
these mappings
we could use them to automatically guide
the transfer of
content and style
bricolage is an algorithm that uses
design mining data
to provide one-click retargeting between
web pages
given two web pages bricolage
automatically transfers the content
from one page into the style and layout
of another
at a glance this seems like a difficult
interaction to enable
but the key point here is that this is
something that
people already do and so we can
use design mining techniques to
understand how
and then leverage that understanding to
build an automated system
to develop this understanding we ran an
online study
we created a crowdsourcing tool for
people to specify correspondences
between pages
given a highlighted segment in the left
page participants were asked to indicate
the corresponding segment on the right
and this process continued until every
segment had been matched
after every fifth match users were
prompted to provide a short rationale
for their decision
now in the data we collected we found
several
important patterns first
many participants use the words use
words like
link menu and image in their submitted
rationales
indicating that a lot of matching is
based on
visual or semantic cues
this pattern is also borne out by the
collected mappings
people match semantically similar
elements together such as
logos navigational bars and search boxes
however not every element in a web page
has strong semantics for these elements
we found that people leverage
the visual structure of the page to
determine where to map them
so one type of structure is ancestry
we call it mapping between pages
ancestry preserving
if once two nodes are matched their
children are matched as well
the mappings collected in our study turn
out to be 53 percent
ancestry preserving on average
another kind of structure is sibling
relationships
we call it mapping sibling preserving if
once two notes are matched
their siblings are matched as well the
mappings collected in our study were
84 sibling preserving on average
and we see that supporting these
structural statistics
there are many words in the collective
rationales that relate to structure
such as layout column and subsection
so this study gives intuition about
how to produce human-like mappings
between pages
we want a matching algorithm that
incorporates both semantic
and structural constraints and can
balance between them
since the page segmentations we're using
are trees
our first strategy was to turn to the
tree matching literature
tree matching algorithms define mappings
between trees by matching together
similar nodes
while simultaneously preserving
hierarchical relationships
across the trees
but it turns out that the tree matching
formalism is too rigid for mapping
between designs
tree matching algorithms rigidly enforce
ancestry
and this constraint is too restrictive
for capturing human mappings
for example if the hero image is here
and the logos are matched together
in these two pages tree matching breaks
because
it's enabled to match the search bars
so we developed an algorithm for
flexible tree matching which
relaxes this rigid ancestry constraint
we accomplish this by adding sibling and
ancestry terms to the tree matching cost
model
which makes ancestry and sibling
preservation soft constraints
and allows the algorithm to balance
between them
just to briefly explain the technical
details we
formulate flexible tree matching as
finding the minimum cost mapping in a
complete bipartite graph
the nodes from the two page
segmentations form the two sides of the
complete bipartite graph
and we define a mapping to be the set of
edges from this graph
such that every node in the two trees is
covered by precisely one edge
and if we look at the cost model the
cost of an edge
in this graph is the sum of three terms
a visual cost
an ancestry cost and a sibling cost
and we if we look at the visual cost the
visual cost is just a weighted euclidean
distance between the website guys
feature vectors
so the edge that connects the h1 headers
will have a much smaller visual cost
than the edge that connects the header
to the image
next let's consider the ancestry cost
term
suppose you fix an edge between these
two container nodes
then the edge matching together two
children
these two tax blocks will have a smaller
ancestry cost
than the edge matching together one
child
and a sibling so the answer she cost
penalizes edges
that fail to preserve ancestry
relationships between the page trees
and the sibling class term works in
pretty much the same way
suppose you fix an edge between the two
headings
then the edge matching together
two siblings these two text blocks will
have a smaller sibling cost
than the edge matching one sibling to a
parent of the node
so the sibling cost penalizes edges
that fail to preserve sibling
relationships between page trees
it turns out that evaluating the cost
model and computing the minimum cost
mapping
is mp complete so we use a stochastic
approximation algorithm that works by
bounding the edge cost
so we pick the edge with the lowest
estimated cost
we fix it in the mapping we then remove
all the edges incident
on its terminal nodes and by pruning
those edges
we can update the bounds on the
remaining edges
and so this process repeats we pick the
best edge
prune and update bounce until we
converge to a mapping
intuitively you can think of this as
first the elements that are semantically
very similar
on the page get mapped together and then
the ancestry
and sibling cost determine how
everything that's left over
gets matched and a nice
feature of the flexible tree matching is
that we can train the parameters of the
algorithm
on the corpus of human mappings that we
collected
and we do this by using the generalized
perceptron algorithm
which is a standard structure prediction
technique
and in this way we can learn the cost
model
that best reproduces human behavior and
subsequently use it
to predict predict mappings between any
pair
of web pages
and in fact this learning works fairly
well
bricolage is able to reproduce human
mappings with nearly 80
accuracy and we show that this careful
balance between
semantic and structural constraints is
essential to producing good mappings
if we remove any of the terms from the
cost model
the predictive power of the algorithm
decreases substantially
so once we have bricolage we can now use
it to rapidly prototype
alternative designs by taking an
existing page
and retargeting that page's content into
new styles
and layouts
now one of the reasons that retargeting
is such
an important problem is because the
number of devices on which people
view web content is exploding manually
retargeting pages
for every possible form factor is
already more or less impossible
what's needed are automatic methods that
adapt
content across devices and design
mining gives us some intuition that it
may be possible to develop
these techniques in a data-driven way
consider the spatial probability
distributions
i showed you before for popular web
elements
but now let's compare how these
distributions change
between desktop and mobile pages
some elements like headers look
pretty much the same on both desktop and
mobile pages
but the distribution for others like
sidebars
change in dramatic ways so
just from this data it seems reasonable
to hope that
we might be able to programmatically
understand
the patterns that designers use when
they map content
across form factors
and we've already made a little progress
in this area
by demonstrating how bricolage can be
used to retarget between different
form factors by training the algorithm
on a set of desktop to mobile mappings
these are still you know early results
but we can for instance
automatically map this desktop page
into two different mobile layouts and
in the future we hope to apply design
mining techniques to this problem
with even greater success
as we look to the future it's important
to recognize that
the vision for design mining is not just
to help us build some
particular set of applications
fundamentally what websitegeist affords
us
is the ability to empirically study
design
at scale instead of relying
on a set of experts to give us the best
practices for web design
we can start building and understanding
from data
in a rigorous way and these ideas aren't
just restricted to the web
as more and more creative work is done
digitally
and shared in the cloud we hope that the
lessons we learn
and the techniques we develop to answer
these questions in web design
can eventually be transferred to other
domains
particularly in light of all of the
recent work
in computer graphics on data driven 3d
modeling
and scene understanding
and design mining can help us do more
than just
build design tools as we start to
ask big questions like what makes a
design beautiful
we can also hope to better understand
how
design and utility are related
for instance one question that comes to
mind is
how google might use design mining to
update their rankings of
site quality and trustworthiness
another important observation is that
while building more sophisticated tools
is exciting
um there's tremendous value to be
had from ju from just making design data
more readily accessible to designers
designers are already living breathing
data-driven generative models and
we know that giving them better access
to the information they care about
can make them more productive efficient
and creative
and this is fundamentally what design
mining is about
bringing scientific rigor and
sophisticated analysis
to the study of creativity eventually
we'd like to be able to understand why
turning to 1950s hot rods for
inspiration
in designing shoes was not only a
sensible decision
but a beautiful powerful and evocative
one
and my hope is that this thesis
takes a first step in this direction
so before i finish there's just an awful
lot of people
that i'd like to thank um
i've been really fortunate to work with
a lot of amazing people
um arvin maxine cesar
and salman you guys are pretty amazing
um
and uh scott thank you
because uh you know for letting me do
all of this work
um you know the research agenda didn't
have an immediate payoff
and i was not always the easiest student
to work with but
i got really lucky because i don't think
i could have had an
advisor who cared more about his
students
and there are so many other people that
i want to thank
my my committee uh pat terry
michael noah thanks for
all of your support and feedback through
the years
the other faculty at stanford and
all the other friends and fellow
students who've
been with me along the way
and and i just want to take one more
minute to
sing out one more person often times
it's
hard to pinpoint where something really
started
but i know exactly where my journey
through grad school
grad school began and i imagine pat
doesn't even remember
sending this email in 2006 but
if he hadn't i wouldn't be standing here
now
and it meant an awful lot to me at the
time
and it means even more to me now
and um last but not least my wonderful
family
um thank you all uh
jerry i you know the best part of grad
school was
getting to work with you and um you know
the best part is that i feel like you
know i
i get to work with you and see you get
excited about the things that i'm
excited about
and i really you know without my parents
i wouldn't be here either um they've
kind of seen
all of the ups and downs of grad school
and
they always know how to keep things in
perspective uh
you know don't be sad because it's not
like your dog died
so with that uh i'm happy to answer all
of your questions
i'm not crying so you can
yes so now that you've created a
programmatic interface to design
have you seen any people suggest
applications that seem completely out of
left field that you never expected like
the world's best pad blocker yeah
actually
the one that i've heard a lot that would
be fascinating to explore is
people want to use design data for
phishing detection
and you know i guess you
you people use things like these
transparent overlays
on top of websites to like you know get
you to click on things that you don't
mean to click on
and give you information you don't mean
to give so
um i think there are a lot of cool
applications
uh that we haven't thought of at all and
you know one of the important things
moving forward is to really make this
data available
um to everyone so that they can build
other design
other crazy design mining applications
did you see the opposite direction what
experience you did design it for with
web designers
that's one thing i feel like we haven't
been able to close the loop on
so that's really i think the next step
in
future work is you know understanding
how like the tools like the search
engine we've built um
actually helps designers in their
process uh you know
the the ways that we're exposing search
through
example driven search or you know dql
like
what what method is actually uh
you know the right method for designers
and when is it useful
um yes i i definitely feel like we've
you know been building all of this
technology and we're finally at a point
where we can actually
do the the cool part
yes how would a two like this deal with
terminal service issues for people
who may not want um this kind of stuff
captured
in mind or made available from the game
yeah i mean the copyright issue is
an interesting one um you know a lot of
this stuff
falls under fair use and we haven't
released bricolage actually
um so you know we're going to proceed
with caution um
you know the first thing we're trying to
do is build the is we've built the
search engine and released it and
i you know right now we are pretty much
giving the same kind of
functionality and exposure that like
google does to all of this content
or something like firebug does to like
actually inspecting
the html but that's going to be an
important thing to consider as we move
forward
okay my last question so you have a way
to find pages that are similar
if you have a way to do that you have a
stream of likes
or knowledge of what people think is
good and you have a way to automatically
evaluate which of say three designs is
the one that most people will
like the most or figure out design
principles
kind of automatically yeah every web
page in the world to find the best one
yeah i mean the issue of quality is
possibly like the hardest
thing that we haven't like to tackle in
the space
like what actually makes a design good
right and and like
i actually think that the search engine
is the first step
in in actually being able to develop
that quality metric because i do
feel like there's a lot of information
we still
want to get from users in terms of like
when they find something useful
and possibly even have them give rich
annotations
to these designs that they find useful
in the search engine um
i just think from the current like uh
you know the current design data we've
mined it's
really hard to still extract that so i
think
you know our we're trying to release the
search engine as both a way to
give people this new kind of ability to
search as well as a way to get more
data from people
yes so you you pointed out fairly early
on
that the dumb and basically doesn't map
on semantics at least not directly you
end up
uh needing to learn this and likewise
you saw that
the dominant css doesn't even map onto
the visual hierarchy of the page
which was in the sense what it was
originally designed to do
so i'm wondering if given sort of from
your perspective sort of tiering on the
side of either semantics or layout
would you recommend any changes to like
the
html or css that you think would make
this all
maintain that that balance but maybe uh
be easier to use
well i mean i think right now the web is
more
it's actually you know people always ask
me this question in the sense that
how much post-processing did you
actually have to do on these
you know doms to get the visual
segmentation and really
it's close you know i would there are
some crazy
web programmers who out there who know
how to like subvert
you know in really malicious ways so
that there's no correspondences
between like the the hierarchy and the
dom and the visual
hierarchy but so i would say that i feel
like
html right now is more in about the
visual hierarchy than
you know this is the semantic one um but
you know moving forward
i think from the last five years what
i've learned is having
the semantics would just make all of
these
it would be much better for all of these
applications and so
that's really what inspired the i think
structural semantics
project is the is the notion that you
know
if we just knew a little bit more about
the role these elements are playing
um in the in the page we could do a lot
more with that
so then as a follow-up to that sort of
the weak working hypothesis of web
design here would be that the
these tools that people have access to
the ways that they know how to
manipulate
the dom css all these things are having
a big impact
probably on the designs that they're
producing
and i'm i'm wondering if that
you may or may not agree with that but
if you do sort of
what are you what is the outcome of that
are we we're just seeing every page look
like twitter bootstraps
i mean that's that's why i think some of
these technologies
like retargeting is so powerful um
because i think
you know there's going to be something
that comes out after twitter bootstrap
or wordpress there's going to be the
next like twitter bootstrap right
and it would be nice if you weren't
always restricted
to these templates or using these
templates in order to make content look
good
it would be nice to kind of break out of
that and
give people more expressive you know
wasted design um that didn't require
them to know
the the nitty-gritty uh details of html
but uh but yeah i think that's like
that's really why
i think like the the retargeting model
is powerful because you could imagine
like
now responsive design is a big thing and
uh you know you don't want to go learn
it but if you had
a few you know twitter bootstuff
templates that you could
just retarget to now your design can be
responsive right
and but there's going to be something
else in the future beyond responsive
design
i don't know what it is yet but you know
that's why i think like
the concept of retargeting and design is
powerful
yes yeah you request so
your last slide was kind of very
evocative right it was the ultimate goal
is aesthetics
but on the other hand all of the data
that you're gathering sort of you know
painfully and with human annotation
doesn't actually have any aesthetic
ratings or judgments or anything in it
wouldn't it be nice to add that and then
use that as part of the
algorithms right yes and um that's
really where we're going with the
this again the search engine because um
now
we feel like we've built something
that's useful to people so there will be
incentives for them to
give more feedback like ratings and
create personal
uh collections of designs that they like
and want to keep around and
as we can you know and then we can start
mining that
as well and the same way that you
crowdsourced alignments and these kind
of more
structural things you could crowdsource
aesthetic judgments and just add it to
website guys so people can use it
this is true i think you know one thing
i've learned is it's nice when there's
actual
like you get better data when there are
incentives um
and like i feel like the search engine
actually
provides these incentives for people to
do a good job
when they're giving these kinds of
ratings right because they personally
want to know these things later on
um and so i think that's a better model
than just crowdsourcing
oh yes how to make
web pages uh this was when we had dialog
connections and so i downloaded things
and looked at them
and that was a very crummy way of
learning and now
that you have website cards you you can
basically look at any example that you
want to right so
how do you think we should change how
you teach people how to design
given that you have these new tools now
yeah i mean
the the great thing is like i think this
couples really well with like
actual like literal like books on web
design right
because you can be reading about
something and then say i want to see 100
ways that people have actually done this
right um
you could be reading about slide shows
and say you know what are all the
different slide
show mechanisms out there um we haven't
done this yet
that's more on the interaction side but
forecasting ahead i think that's
that's the power of website guys is like
you know it doesn't
kind of change the books are still
valuable because they
have all of these guidelines and
annotations but you can have a richer
understanding
much more quickly and i think that's
what really differentiate differentiates
people
and novices from experts is that like
experts have really had the time to like
look at a lot more examples and digest
them
and now you're giving you know novices a
way to
more quickly digest more examples right